my shopping guide to getting the finest
fish
when i buy my fish i only want the
freshest and the best
and if anyone knows how to get the best
it's roger kent barton he's been buying
and selling fish at the world famous
billings gate market in london for over
50 years
i love fish
i think it's the greatest food of all
time i sell literally every variety
there is i could feed you a different
fish
365 days a year this guy really knows
how to sniff out the good from the bad
all fish smell different the longer it's
around
the more fishy it will smell
when it's lovely and fresh
it doesn't smell whenever you're gonna
buy fish don't be frightened get your
nose right into it don't go like that
get it into it smell it
smells delightful
it smells what i call salmony and it's
lovely barramundi it's a lovely fish the
way to tell good fish is look at it
closely it's shining it's still got the
bloom on it his eyes are as bright as
yours look in the gill lovely and red
put it in the bag for the gentleman
please people should always be asking
about their fish
what kind of fish is it where's it come
from a nice salmon 19 pound it's a
bargain at 20 pounds roger's right
salmon's brilliant value and a great
all-rounder really healthy and super
delicious here's a quick look at the
different cuts and how to use them
[Music]
whole salmon always impresses it's
fantastic stuffed and steamed either in
a fish kettle or in the oven wrapped in
foil
steaks are great value and brilliant
baked a cider salmon is perfect for
poaching home curing or baking in pastry
the fillet is so versatile easy fast to
cook and great for pan frying
smoked salmon delicious cooked or raw i
love it with scrambled eggs
[Music]
broadly there's white fish
and there's oily fish they come under
two different sections here we have
white fish
it's lovely it's cold it's the best cod
in the world it comes to a place called
peterhead it's nice and white
the whiter the better one of the most
oily fish you'll find mackerel there it
is
lovely color
with most fish the fresher they are the
harder they are if you're not well and
you're ill
have a mackerel
sprats otherwise known as top hats here
we have flat fish and these are known as
place as you can see they've got spots
the redder they are the fresher they are
it really is a lovely fish to eat king
jules couldn't have better for fish
fresh enough for royalty follow your
fishmonger's advice and you'll never
ever have another dodgy dover sole again
muscles with celery and chili
[Music]
first prep the veg chopped spring onions
shallots
a clove of garlic
and chili to taste
then thinly slice celery
add a bay leaf and thyme
veg ready
[Music]
add oil to a pan and fry
[Music]
season
then add mussels and stir
mussels one of my favorite shellfish
cheap healthy and delicious
cover and sting for a couple of minutes
as the muscles open add vermouth and
aromatic 45 wine
[Music]
and 150 ml of dry white wine
on a high heat reduce the liquid to
create a sauce
discard any mussels that are still shut
[Music]
then finish with creme fraiche and
chopped parsley
[Music]
minimal prep and cooked in less than 10
minutes my muscles with celery and chili
impressive affordable and super speedy
i've got some stunning and i mean
stunning lobsters
and i'll be cooking them very simply
with chilli and garlic butter serving
them with bloody mary linguini
[Music]
i'm going to start with the pasta sauce
i love the indulgence in this dish
if i was doing this for the kids i'd
scrap the vodka and just do like a
virgin mary
but
it's a bit of a grown ups dish
now pan nice and hot splash of olive oil
onions in
seasoning touch of salt and pepper
garlic
be nice and generous with the garlic
it's not just your average tomato sauce
it's a royal stunning tomato sauce and
you're in for a big treat
season your onions and garlic for the
tabasco
that will give that really nice lift a
little pinch of celery salt
spice that up with worcester sauce
it instantly colors the tomatoes goes
brilliantly well with a celery salt
tabasco and that nice caramelized garlic
a little light sprinkling of sugar all
the worcester sauce
has reduced down we've got this nice
sweet spicy sticky garlicky
onion base
glazed with a couple of spoons of vodka
in
lovely
chopped tomatoes in
a little touch of water
look at the colour of that sauce
check the seasoning
that's delicious bring that up to the
boil and cook it out six to eight
minutes reduce it down slowly turn down
the gas and let that simmer
with my sauce simmering i can move on to
a delicious breadcrumb topping to dress
my linguini
i'll fry off my breadcrumbs get them
nice and crispy but don't put too much
oil in there otherwise the bread will
just absorb it they become greasy
beautifully season them
and they go really nice and golden brown
30 seconds before they come out flat
leaf parsley roll that through
your breadcrumbs
and that is gonna finish the linguine on
top
you can hear how crispy they are
before i cook the linguini i'm gonna
make the chili butter that will flavour
my lobster
get your chili and slice it i wanna take
advantage of all those seeds
chili in
a touch of salt
a nice clove of garlic
and get some
[Music]
parsley start breaking that down but i'm
looking for a lovely garlic chili paste
exactly like that
now don't overdo it with the butter
herb butters are a great way to flavor
fish and meat they can be used as a
stuffing in dishes like chicken kiev or
added towards the end of a dish as a
delicious glaze
lobsters
they're already cooked so
firmly place the lobster flat on your
board there's a little crisscross here
line there and line going across
put the point of the knife in and just
push through
the head
turn the lobster around
cut through the lobster
snap the legs off
snap the claws off just get the back of
your knife
crack them
spread that beautiful butter on
go into the heads as well
and then the claws
take off bits of the shell
and get little bits of butter in there
this can be done way in advance for me
the longer that chili butter sits on top
of that lobster the better the flavor
especially when they hit the grill
while my lobster firms up in the fridge
i can finish cooking my linguini
water
brought up to the boil
seasoned nicely and a little touch of
olive oil
now linguine in first that's going to
take the longest
eight to ten minutes
in
as linguine starts softening at the
bottom just gently turn that around
always wait the linguine is nice and
soft that way you don't break those nice
strands
give that a good mix get your lid back
on
[Music]
and bring that to the ball rapidly
after eight to ten minutes my linguine
should be perfect
you want it al dente slightly firm
not too chewy
absolutely spot on
drain that
into a colander
shake a little bit of water from the
pasta into my sauce and she goes
start twisting
the linguini
around i want that bloody mary spicing
up the linguini
always hold up the center of the pan
first and place it onto the plate
let go of that nice big lump
by doing this you'll get a mountainous
pile of spaghetti with more body
then generously cover that your crispy
breadcrumbs absolutely beautiful
last but not least i need to cook my
chilled herb buttered lobsters on a
smoking hot griddle
that butter's gotten really nice and
firm so the idea is
snapping that
and grilling
the smell of that chili and garlic
butter is extraordinary because the
lobster's cooked all you're doing is
grilling that delicious spicy chili
butter you just want that mark of the
char quickly on the lobster
turn that over
smell is incredible
[Music]
now get that on
[Music]
you can understand why it is proper
special occasion food because
that is mind-blowing
[Music]
griddled lobster with chili and garlic
butter served with a boozy bloody merry
linguine a sensational special occasion
lunch
you